where's your place and fever I believe
together now we're gonna get straight
into it there - V - action the first
ever to be two people 17-game so me me
and Royce right I don't want to use that
what we're doing is it okay means that
we've got this it's getting as you want
so that's my rhoids do you play fifa of
course
first I like to hear all I hear is
actually quite decently yeah he's one of
the better players
yeah we'll be the underdogs that's fine
that's okay wait about this about being
in a better position right so are we
realistically yeah play classic everyone
classic left as well yeah well I think
sure why don't we thinking should we go
you've been Dortmund I'm gonna go
dormant so I can use Royce this make it
really easy right next to me you can
have a double double double Royce I will
go for him let's do this that's it game
ready you guys ready let's jump straight
in turn your feet so come on let's do
this so how does it feel to be the diva
17 cover starts yeah it's amazing I mean
I play fifa so so a long time and for me
it's it's a dream and time again what
there were you when they told you that
you I was with my friends yeah I was
with my friends and just sitting home
and play fifa and here we go three
teammates all right all right
take that I am on the blue cursor let's
get straight in there Zed no messing
about
oh yeah we're not friends the next few
minutes there are enemies
already already I see it William being
here we go oh hello we've got this we've
got this pasta there you go just feeling
it out some new games very good let's go
through block oh it's Royce himself
who's green oh that's a great ball no no
no no that's all right I said boy scored
yeah I just what a go briefly please
good this is all that was good a good
pass yes perfect pass oh man what a goal
go ask questions about them on the way
there forget about that that's fine it's
about a heaven again expensive
now Roy not to have you heard but just
gonna be competitive FIFA now so we
could possibly be on the same team yes
oh please
back to you I like it wait I was I was
holding the wrong way around
I'm playing this is great
perfect perfect look at that through
nice right and then the finish is it up
the pose I mean I thought that was going
over that was a good one laughs all
right there's a full sense of security
and that's a great start like I'm not
sure if I'm ready for such champions
Mochis yeah give me a few weeks marker
is actually decent one way oh [ __ ] a
shot he would have scored unlucky Oh now
for back at home what what's your team
there you go with don't want the first
Norman of course I like that I'm sorry
you've got to be outside lots of people
can see all my ways another penalty good
plan alright I wouldn't get out of these
balls edge oh my god what a long shot
call me Dad let's just call me gotta
breathe I'm gonna send it out there
that's when this that's nice okay
you guys crossed a half all right oh you
go there you go absolutely everybody saw
that
oh she tries to be a guy on the line
this is okay this is a new free-kick
mode you got this I'm counting on you
let's just see what happens that could
go anywhere I mean it takes a lot of
getting used to this new free-kick set
piece but when you get it it's so good
yeah we got that that's nice all right
judges beautiful
welcome Hannover what about another one
Oh
mommy a very nice there we go better
from us on the back dangerous right
there just trying some tricks we're not
Paul it's a great book here we go wrap
it he's rapid look at that that's a
shielding we saw earlier Spencer so good
better all right good time shareable
star
we just didn't I was holding the
controller the wrong way I showed you
now we're now we're going Phil I was
doing the same thing
yes William Wow Goodwin middle beautiful
I like it through Bach Oh would you
later
that's it it's nice
wha-wha-what Robbins nearly all right
order always three coming I was gonna
try out the new corners with the
crosshair alright okay this is the new
corner okay see there this thing in the
middle
alright I try and deliver it in this
area here eautiful you don't know that's
the ball look at this guy voice oh man
guys come on we could have a really good
have we seen some pretty good goals
I mean we her total domination really I
think like orchestra in the middle as
well really yeah this may it's meant to
be
but we can get it it's just welcome
getting to go that's nice
Oh rats putting out I'll look at that
ball first bad pass we not win that win
that well up oh whoops there's a little
dangerous
I stay well done sorry I started I'm
lucky oh oh you got this said I believe
in you tomorrow that was we got this
we're back in this a poultry Istanbul
good god Thomas Muller comeback is on
read that here wasn't purposed by the
way okay and that was obviously all come
on boys they're nervous they nervous I
can feel very nervous theme is decent oh
let's get on hang on what angle alright
where's he gonna put it Marco with the
cross we get out go in middle
at the top it will get another two girls
here
Oh second yellow yellow it's gone
wet cut alone so ideal but is he gone
yes I love that from the rest let the
game fire oh I agree let's just keep
going
watch the game off keep the good spirit
alive be ready look at this Spencer he's
dancing can I kill it ha all right we're
not
what's outside nice let's go to many
players here oh really
I'm still got it I still got it middle
middle ok mommy ain't say more one more
yes Noah what a plague that was good to
me get this out there it is
there did Noah funny - I'm gonna send it
long go go go go go wins what massive
kicks only first finish if I make it red
that that is with Royce all right
get me this ball back come on mate come
on he's just holding it in the corner
now who can tell isn't professional look
at that look at that bar oh here we go
run off me good read
oh he can oh it's not too late
naturally the post office heard three
two - good game really good game is
second off this is been a game of two
halves we just slow starters we'd said
tickets are it hard to stop he knows how
to do it back on the bar right okay I'm
scared of this one I was actually really
good throw
nothing sitting out oh man I thought
that was fire
calm down 83rd minute you always
bitching oh he's going with Royce if he
scores this these girls they said bye to
him he's got him for it no no way all
right on target
let's do this five minutes okay not even
good
oh yes a lot oh yes it's dead this is
our moment for the draw
oh yeah perfect
Alonso come on oh yeah now the tackles
in alright good read good read good
match the game
well fight good game